here's a bottle on your shelf okay  that's a passive centrifuge  that is a 1G centrifuge think about it  that way gotcha you're sitting here in  Earth's gravity all right and in Earth's  gravity which is 1g it will settle  things out at the rate that you see  okay  so now how do I create artificial  gravity science fiction does it in space  correctly all the time what do they do  they make the space station spin so you  spin it up and if you spin you create  like this centrifugal force that you  feel as you're out on the rim  and that's basically a centrifuge  all right so you can calculate what  speed you'd have to rotate it to field  1G  right and if you do that and you take  out your bottle that's a 1G centrifuge  that's what you're experiencing sitting  here on Earth with a bottle on your  table